este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a das
link no sé vosotros pero entre unas
cosas y otras yo me paso el día entre el
ordenador y la tablet que si trabajo que
sin leer noticias que si una serie que
te tiene enganchado que al final acabas
utilizando cientos de webs donde tienes
que lograr te claro utilizar la misma
contraseña en todas las webs no es una
buena idea si quieres minimizar tu
vulnerabilidad en la red
entonces como estar protegido de la
manera más segura invirtiendo el menor
tiempo posible pues aquí amigos es donde
entra das line para ayudarnos
daschle y nos va ayudar a generar
contraseñas seguras y cada vez que una
web te pide introducirlas pues vas a
poder rellenarlas fácilmente o por
ejemplo puedes guardar la info de tus
tarjetas para tenerlo todo siempre a
mano es súper cómodo vamos yo
personalmente esta función la uso un
montón das lane también te proporciona
el monitoreo de la dar web que consiste
en escanear la web en busca de datos
personales filtrados o robados además
incluye un servicio vpn con selección de
países para todos tus dispositivos de
tal forma que puedas navegar por redes
públicas como
aeropuerto dos cafeterías de forma
siempre segura y anónima haz tu vida más
sencilla y vengas link.com visual
polític s para usar das line de forma
totalmente gratuita en tu primer
dispositivo y si decides que te gusta y
que quieres irte a la versión premium
usa nuestro código visual polític s para
tener un 10% de descuento y ahora ahora
vayamos con el vídeo de hoy
[Aplausos]
[Música]
en situaciones normales toda la economía
de un país se orienta fundamentalmente a
crear riqueza y atender la demanda de
bienes y servicios de la gente pero qué
ocurre cuando las cosas cambian y de
repente algún acontecimiento
extraordinario cobra una relevancia
desorbitada
pensad por ejemplo en una pandemia como
la que estamos viviendo ahora con el
sars coronavirus 2 o también en una
guerra
[Música]
como os podéis imaginar en este tipo de
situaciones las prioridades de las
personas y también de los gobiernos
cambian radicalmente de la noche a la
mañana y con ellas las necesidades de
producción de repente la demanda cambia
y hay que producir lo más rápidamente
posible cosas muy diferentes en el caso
de una pandemia material médico en el
caso de una guerra todo tipo de armas y
municiones
pues bien es en estos casos cuando se
empieza a hablar de economía de guerra
un concepto que a día de hoy se ha
puesto en marcha en muchos países por
culpa precisamente del coronavirus
[Música]
ahora bien como se puede poner en marcha
una economía de guerra qué capacidad
tienen los gobiernos para orientar toda
la producción nacional en una misma
dirección cómo reaccionar ante
situaciones absolutamente
extraordinarias
[Música]
amigos amigas en este vídeo vamos a
responder a todas estas preguntas y lo
vamos a hacer
echando un vistazo a la historia
especialmente a la historia de los eeuu
os venís con nosotros a este pequeño
viaje por la historia pues a por ello
[Música]
la locomotora de guerra
para indagar cómo un país puede
transformar a toda velocidad su
estructura productiva para enfrentarse a
un acontecimiento extraordinario tenemos
que remontarnos hasta la segunda guerra
mundial ahí vamos a encontrar el mejor
ejemplo de una economía de guerra
y es que veréis aunque os puede parecer
increíble lo cierto es que hasta la
primera mitad del siglo 20 los eeuu eran
un país básicamente pacífico
aislacionista vamos que en materia
política prácticamente pasaba del resto
del mundo quién lo diría verdad
históricamente los eeuu no eran muy
partidarios de meterse en líos ajenos
era una actividad que conllevaba muchos
sacrificios y costaba mucho dinero
precisamente por eso prácticamente hasta
principios del siglo 20 salvo por alguna
que otra acción muy concreta eeuu era
considerado como un país neutral un país
no intervencionista en materia de
política exterior durante ese tiempo los
principios libertarios de los padres
fundadores aún recién en la política
norteamericana
sin embargo con la llegada del siglo 20
todo esto empezó poco a poco a cambiar y
los eeuu comenzaron a tener una
presencia internacional cada vez más y
más importante en un primer momento el
objetivo esencial era garantizar la
seguridad del comercio pero con el
tiempo como todos sabemos las cuestiones
políticas comenzaron a cobrar más y más
peso
el caso es que ese nuevo papel les
condujo por ejemplo a participar en la
primera guerra mundial en contra del
imperio alemán y años más tarde en la
segunda aunque por motivos muy
diferentes
[Música]
en este caso fue el imperio de japón con
el famoso y cinematográfico ataque de
pearl harbor el que literalmente empujó
a eeuu a la guerra
[Música]
amigos del ataque de pearl harbor fue
uno de esos acontecimientos que
contribuyen a cambiar la historia
en el ataque sucediendo en diciembre de
1941 eeuu no solo perdió más de 2400
conciudadanos sino también buena parte
de su flota del pacífico que estaba
estacionada en este puerto hawaiano el
ataque se saldó con ocho barcos hundidos
y otros once con daños de diversa
gravedad
esto supuso básicamente el mayor golpe
militar recibido en su territorio por
los eeuu
m
en la práctica este ataque metió al país
de lleno en la segunda guerra mundial
con ello de la noche a la mañana cambió
radicalmente la forma en la que los
americanos vivían y producían y es que
de repente toda la industria del país se
puso al servicio del ejército y del
estado
y esto no fue algo fortuito se coordinó
a través de una agencia creada por el
propio presidente roosevelt la word
production board o junta de producción
de guerra que se estableció el día 16 de
enero de 1942 pocos días después del
ataque japonés
ahora bien la pregunta es para qué
servía realmente esta junta pues fijaos
entre otras cosas
esta junta coordinó la transformación de
la industria civil de tal forma que
cualquier fábrica que tuviera capacidad
de hacerlo se puso manos a la obra
inmediatamente para adaptarse a la
producción de todo tipo de equipos
militares armas vehículos tanques
municiones equipo de intendencia
etcétera etcétera
un buen ejemplo fue el caso de la
industria del automóvil
el cambio fue radical mientras que en el
año 1941 se produjeron en eeuu unos 3
millones de vehículos en 1943 por
ejemplo se fabricaron apenas 139 si lo
habéis escuchado bien 139 vehículos
civiles fabricados en todo un año
en 1944 tan solo 610 o sea menos de 1000
coches en dos años sin embargo al mismo
tiempo la ilustre estadounidense trabajó
a destajo durante toda la segunda guerra
mundial y en 1945 la mitad de toda la
producción industrial del mundo estaba
en este país en eeuu esta capacidad de
producción fue vital para el devenir de
los acontecimientos todo el poder
industrial de los eeuu se concentró en
una única misión ganar la guerra
y vamos a perder
de esta forma la industria automotriz
comenzó a fabricar masivamente tanques
camiones armas de fuego y motores de
avión de hecho las fábricas de detroit
empezaron a mostrar imágenes tan
insólitas como esta
líneas de tanques listos para enviar al
frente de batallas
por supuesto ese no fue el único cambio
la producción industrial demandaba más y
más mano de obra y claro como buena
parte de los hombres sanos en edad de
trabajar eran reclutados como soldados
millones de mujeres que antes se
quedaban en el hogar y gran parte de la
población negra que hasta ese momento
había sido marginada a roles inferiores
se pusieron a trabajar en la industria
no fue solo un cambio económico sino que
comenzó una auténtica transformación
social
lo más paradójico de todo es que durante
todo este periodo durante el que estuvo
en vigor la junta de producción de
guerra la economía norteamericana
funcionó en gran medida como una
economía socialista si se mantuvo la
iniciativa privada pero las principales
decisiones se tomaron de forma
centralizada en última instancia el
gobierno federal era el que decidía
desde washington cómo distribuir las
materias primas a qué industrias se
repartían dónde se realizaban las
inversiones e incluso que se fabricaba y
en qué cantidad
incluso se impusieron también medidas de
racionamiento y controles de precios
para toda la población
en definitiva prácticamente toda la
economía pasó a estar controlada por el
estado y al servicio de las necesidades
que marcaban las campañas militares
por supuesto todo esto tuvo
consecuencias
[Música]
el coste de la contienda fue tan alto
debido a la gigantesca inyección de
gasto público financiado con deuda que
en 1945 al finalizar la guerra la deuda
pública se había multiplicado por 5
respecto al momento inicial
[Música]
y eso a pesar de la ley de ingresos de
1942 que aumentó el número de personas
que debían pagar impuestos de 13 a 50
millones de personas casi 4 veces más
[Música]
y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando pero a
ver
alberto entonces parece que todo
funcionó a las mil maravillas no es así
pues sí y no
[Aplausos]
no os equivoquéis la clave no estuvo en
la junta de producción sino en la enorme
superioridad industrial que los eeuu
habían logrado durante los años
precedentes
en eso y en que esta junta nunca
expropió los activos ni los medios de
producción de las empresas
lo que hizo ante una situación
absolutamente extrema fue simplemente
coordinarlos con un objetivo sustituir
la producción para la gente por una
producción mucho más concreta la
producción para la guerra
ahora bien esta no fue la única ocasión
en la que eeuu puso en marcha medidas de
este tipo o suena de algo el año 1950
[Música]
exacto seguro que muchos lo habéis
adivinado la guerra de korea
la guerra de korea fue una larga y dura
contienda que tuvo lugar entre los años
1950 y 1953 en ella se enfrentaron el
bloque comunista de corea del norte y
china contra el bloque formado por corea
del sur eeuu y otros muchos países que
actuaron bajo mandato de naciones unidas
entre ellos por ejemplo colombia
una nueva guerra una dura guerra apenas
unos años después de terminada la
segunda guerra mundial lo que
evidentemente supuso un nuevo esfuerzo
que necesitó también de medidas
extraordinarias
en este caso el presidente truman
impulsó la defense production act o la
ley de producción de la defensa de 1950
esta ley fue una especie de secuela de
la junta de producción de guerra de la
segunda guerra mundial que hemos visto
pero con algunas diferencias por ejemplo
bajo esta ley en lugar de ser el
gobierno y que directamente gestiona la
producción y controlar los precios lo
que hace principalmente es priorizar los
contratos del gobierno estadounidense
sobre todos los demás es decir para que
nos entendamos si el gobierno pide algo
tiene preferencias
también puede ordenar la ampliación de
la producción de ciertos productos o
cambios puntuales en las líneas de
producción pero lo más curioso de esta
ley es que en buena medida todavía hoy
sigue en vigor y también que su uso no
ha sido nada pero que nada excepcional
de hecho los poderes emanados de esta
ley en algunas de sus diferentes formas
son usados por el departamento de
defensa para realizar cerca de
trescientos mil trescientos mil pedidos
cada año
y ojo no se trata sólo del departamento
de defensa por ejemplo según un informe
del congreso de los eeuu tan solo la
fema la agencia federal para el manejo
de emergencias recurrió a esta ley en
más de mil ocasiones durante el año 2018
por todo esto no debe extrañarnos que en
una situación tan grave como la que
estamos viviendo con el sars coronavirus
2 el gobierno federal haya recurrido a
los poderes que otorga precisamente esta
ley para hacerla frente
acentos
la guerra contra el enemigo invisible
si hay algo que está uniendo a los
presidentes de todo el mundo es la
retórica que están empleando en la lucha
contra lisa es coronavirus dos son
aunque aunque el zenit effects
transmitió este mensaje por supuesto con
la prudencia exigible en medio de una
guerra nunca antes librada our world
telesur sea el ser word en work fighting
en intensivo m
ahora bien mucha gente ha criticado el
empleo de estos términos para referirse
a una batalla que al fin y al cabo y
sanitaria pero y si realmente no es algo
tan diferente a un estado de guerra como
pensamos al fin y al cabo desde el punto
de vista productivo económico casi que
podríamos llegar a decir que se trata de
una guerra con todas las consecuencias
os lo hemos contado las medidas de
cuarentena y confinamiento obligatorio
están causando unos estragos económicos
sin precedentes de hecho el fondo
monetario internacional habla ya de la
mayor contracción económica desde el
crac de 1929
desde 1929 el fmi predice la peor crisis
desde la gran depresión es algo que
seguro nos sorprende vamos a ver si la
gente no sale de casa e incluso no puede
trabajar
es lógico que tanto la producción como
el consumo o las inversiones se
derrumben al menos durante un tiempo
y amigos este escenario es de hecho lo
más parecido a una guerra que
probablemente muchos de nosotros vivamos
en toda nuestra vida
precisamente por este motivo y con el
objetivo de garantizar que la producción
se centre en dotar a los sanitarios de
materiales para poder protegerse y
salvar vidas se han puesto en marcha
medidas extraordinarias que en algunos
casos recuerdan mucho a las adoptadas en
el pasado
por ejemplo el presidente de donald
trump tras alguna que otra reticencia y
muchos retrasos recurrió finalmente a la
ley de producción de defensa creada
durante la guerra de corea
por cierto fijaos que giro vio la casa
blanca esto es en referencia a la
aplicación de esta ley que es la que
habilita el presidente el día 22 de
marzo del 2020 no somos un país basado
nacionalizar nuestros negocios ya ver a
una persona de venezuela y pregúntenle
cómo ha funcionado la nacionalización de
sus empresas no muy bien
donald trump por supuesto la ley no
habla en nacionalizaciones pero bueno ya
sabéis cómo estamos así
[Música]
el caso es que pocos días después ante
la enorme escasez de materiales
sanitarios y de respiradores nos
encontramos con una noticia como ésta
que permite una orden bajo la ley de
producción de defensa para asegurar más
respiradores amigos bajo esta orden por
ejemplo empresas como general motors que
como todos sabéis se dedica a fabricar
automóviles se ve obligada a cambiar su
producción y empezar a fabricar lo antes
posible respiradores
y la pregunta es por qué trampa a pesar
de su oposición inicial decidió recurrir
en una medida tan tan drástica pues por
noticias como estas
ayer se publica una guía para determinar
qué pacientes deberían acceder a
respiradores y claro la escasez de
respiradores pues provoca la selección
de los pacientes que pueden acceder a
ser tratados con uno es decir
básicamente obliga a determinar quién
vive y quién muere
y precisamente la falta de acción de la
administración trump para coordinar la
respuesta sanitaria ha sido una de las
principales acusaciones que se le están
haciendo al presidente 24 de marzo el
presidente dijo que era una guerra es
una guerra entonces actuamos como si
fuera una guerra sólo el gobierno
federal tiene ese poder y no ejercerlo
es inexplicable para mí por más que lo
intente no puedo entender la reticencia
a usar la ley de producción de defensa
andrew cuomo gobernador de nueva york y
lo cierto amigos es que la
administración trump no parece está
haciendo nada pero que nada ágiles 3 de
abril trampa aún no ha pedido ningún
respirador a general motors a pesar de
afirmar que estaba usando poderes de
tiempos de guerra para forzar su
producción casi una semana después de
recurrir a sus poderes bajo una ley de
la época de la guerra de corea la
administración del presidente de donald
trump aún no ha hecho ningún pedido
formal de ninguna de estas máquinas pero
de todo esto ya os hablamos hace poco
tiempo en un vídeo que por si no lo
habéis visto os lo dejamos en la
descripción el caso amigos es que esto
es lo que se conoce como una economía de
guerra cuando de repente se toman
medidas para que el sistema productivo
se centre en atender una determinada
necesidad por encima de
[Aplausos]
de momento ante esta crisis de el
coronavirus parece que la administración
trump ha decidido no aplicar un
escenario de economía de guerra más allá
de algún que otro hecho puntual
[Música]
y la cuestión es debería hacerlo
realmente pensáis que un gobierno que no
vio venir la crisis sanitaria va a ser
la parte más indicada para coordinar
velozmente todas las medidas que se
necesitan no sería quizás acaso mejor
utilizar criterios de mercado como por
ejemplo concursos públicos de
suministros o pedidos generosamente
retribuidos voy a un país y superar una
crisis aislándose del resto del mundo va
a ser la burocracia del estado
suficientemente rápida
estas son las preguntas que se hacen
quienes no son partidarios de tomar este
tipo de iniciativas y el caso es que por
ejemplo en españa las empresas han
actuado con más eficacia que el propio
gobierno pero en cualquier caso esta es
la pregunta la gran pregunta deberían
los gobiernos ante situaciones así
declarar y aplicar una economía de
guerra como ya lo hizo por ejemplo de
eeuu durante la segunda guerra mundial o
la guerra de korea creo que es un debate
muy interesante
dejadnos vuestras opiniones abajo en los
comentarios y si este vídeo os ha
resultado interesante no olvidéis darle
al botón de like un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]